this episode of real engineering is
brought to you by Skillshare home to
over 20,000 classes that could teach you
a new life skill
the humble disc record is not often
properly recognized for the impact its
development had on the modern world on
the face of it these records are just
consumer products that allow music to be
sold to the masses a concept that itself
only reached the mass market about a
hundred years ago the truth is the
impact of this technology goes way
beyond consumption of pop music in some
way the records closest comparison is
the printing press the printing press is
often considered to be one of the most
important inventions in history due to
its ability to quickly and accurately
reproduce ideas in written word which in
turn greatly accelerated the transfer
and exchange of knowledge the ability to
press audio to record so that it can be
reproduced in scale did the exact same
thing for audio it functioned as a
vector for cultural exchange and the
revolution in recording technology
assured in by electronic and audio
engineers that developed the technology
is the foundation upon which modern
communication systems stand upon of
course these days most of the music we
consume is digital the internet has
changed not only the way we consume
music but also the amount of music and
the music itself curiously while this is
happening vinyl is seen a year-on-year
increase in sales even more curious is
the fact that half of the people who buy
an album on vinyl stream at first it
remains a point of contention whether
analog formats such as vinyl are
actually superior to their modern dave
digital counterparts is vinyls
resurgence just consumers seen
yesteryears technology through
rose-tinted glasses a yearning for a
physical connection to their music or
does the music really sound better on
vinyl to understand the differences
between these two we first need to
understand the commonalities no matter
which format is used analog or digital
both require audio data to be created by
a recording device the simplest of these
would be the microphone which turns air
pressure into either a digital or analog
signal which can be replayed as an
electrical analog signal this process
was first put into use in 1877 by Thomas
Edison
while working on the telephone Edison
decided that it would be worth
investigating if sound could be recorded
for later reproduction Edison designed a
rotatable cylinder disc wrapped in tin
foil which was turned by a hand crank
attached to the disc was a needle which
in turn attached to the mouthpiece which
adjusted the pressure of the needle on
the disc
Edison talked into the mouthpiece while
turning the hand crank at a constant
rate and as predicted the pressure of
the sound ways imprinted a proportional
indentation which was analogous to the
sound his voice created when he finished
recording he returned the needle to the
start the indentations which were caused
by his voice could now be played back by
rotating the cylinder this invention the
phonograph was the first example of
playable recorded sound and for all
intents and purposes the vinyl record is
essentially an iteration of this
technology the first vinyl record was
pressed in 1948 by Columbia specifically
it was this recording on 12-inch vinyl
records work on the same principle as
Edison's phonograph a 3d representation
of a sound wave is physically pressed
onto a vinyl record an impression is
first created by a cutting head the
cutting head creates an impression that
is a direct analogue of the sound wave
this process creates a master that will
go on to create a Stamper that molds
each record when a record is played the
frequency of the wave that you will hear
will depend on how stretched out the
wave is on the media and the volume will
depend on the size or amplitude of the
wave this audio information will be
pressed onto the vinyl in one of three
fashions via horizontal modulation
vertical modulation or via a compromise
modulation of 45 degrees horizontal
modulation is always preferable over
vertical modulation and this is because
the vertical modulation leads to more
distortion and allows for less amplitude
due to the inability for the stylus to
track the groove and also a propensity
for the needle to bounce off the wave if
the amplitude is too high but if we run
with only horizontal modulation we can
only play audio in mono and we don't
have stereo separation of sound
accordingly we use a compromise
modulation of 45 degrees in order
to allow separation of audio for mono to
stereo as the stylus follows the groove
moves the Magnus wrapped in a small coil
of copper wire this causes an electric
current that corresponds to the groove
on the vinyl which in turn corresponds
to the physical sound waves that were
originally recorded and the electric
current can now cause a physical
movement of the speakers which will
reproduce that sound pretty faithfully
some vinyl enthusiasts argue that this
smooth continuous reproduction of sound
from analog to analog is more faithful
than digital music part of this argument
stems from the difference in how digital
music is reproduced high-quality digital
audio data is typically sampled 44,000
100 times per second close inspection of
the wave function produced from binary
code shows that rather than the audio
data being smooth and constant like real
life the audio data is jagged and
technically non continuous because there
is an infinite amount of data between
each second of audio we have to sample
the audio in regular intervals to
minimize the size for a digital file
comparing this to the smooth continuous
waveform that is imprinted in vinyl you
would think this might cause some loss
in information whether there is a loss
of information or not depends on whether
the 44,100 samples right is high enough
to be functionally the same an answer to
this was proposed in 1928 in a pivotal
paper published by Swedish American
electronic engineer Harry Nyquist and
was subsequently proven by Claude
Shannon in 1949 they simply found that
to recreate a frequency we only need to
sample each individual wave at least
twice if not the frequency will be
digitized with a lower frequency the
maximum perceivable frequency a human
ear can detect is 20,000 Hertz and so
digital recordings with a sampling rate
of 44,000 Hertz can capture even the
highest frequency possible thus the
sound produced by speaker using digital
audio is effectively the same sound as
analog recordings in this case the
argument that analog recordings are more
faithful does not meet the scrutiny of
science and in theory digital and analog
music recordings should sound
functionally the same if played on the
same equipment the argument does not end
here though there are some constraints
to how sound can be
recorded on vinyl interestingly these
constraints largely explained both vinyl
enthusiasts preference for the media and
also why some might argue that digital
recordings are a superior format for
storing audio the major constraint that
impacts vinyl is simply its limit in
data storage this is simple to
understand a 12-inch record can only
hold so much information in the format
we've described each rotation of the
record takes 1.8 seconds the next
question is how many times each 12-inch
record can rotate two things affect this
the frequencies found in bass notes
require the groove of the record to
swing up wider just as a speaker also
thumps out wider when a plays bass waves
of higher amplitude that produce louder
sounds also require wider grooves this
means that both low frequency sounds and
loud sounds both eat up valuable vinyl
real estate and this in turn means that
if your record has bass or is loud like
most contemporary music there's not
going to be a whole lot of space on the
record for your songs the net impact of
this is that there is a volume and time
constraint on vinyl record that does not
apply to digital music which has huge
ramifications for how we listen to music
and how music is created and mastered
finals limitations do not end here if
the frequency is low and the amplitude
too high the stylus can become prone to
bounding off the wave due to the path
the stylus has to take up the wave at
speed this can cause the record to
bounce around and skip if not accounted
for accordingly bass needs to be Center
panned in the mix and a specific mix has
to be applied to the music recorded to
vinyl to stop this from happening high
frequency sounds also need to be taken
into consideration while cutting a vinyl
record the issue is commonly referred to
as the sibilance issue
sibilance is an unpleasant hissing sound
associated with s sounds and other high
frequencies that anyone has watched my
older videos will be painfully aware of
high frequency waves caused to
fundamental problems in vinyl high
frequency sounds mean the waves are very
tight together the stylus has to surf
these waves and turn extremely tight
corners when the curvature of the groove
becomes tighter than the tip of the
radius of the stylus the stylus will
begin to plow through the groove and you
will end up with distortion on top of
this extremely high frequency waves can
lead to the
putting head that cuts the record to
overheat this is simply a matter of the
coding head having to take a longer path
and having to do more work to cut these
ways the overheating can lead to
inaccuracy in the coding process and in
turn to noise and distortion on the
final record to counteracting negative
effects that extreme low end and high
end frequencies have on vinyl a group of
American engineers developed what became
known as The Recording Industry
Association of America curve in the 40s
and 50s the RIAA is an equalization
scheme that is applied to the sound
before the master lacquer is caused in
essence this curve reduces base content
and boost traveled in the record without
this curve low frequencies take up so
much space that each 12-inch LP would
only allow for five minutes of music in
addition boosting the treble hugely
lowers the surface noise that final can
produce due to the path the stylus takes
this is also why a turntable requires a
special phono preamp in addition to
amplifying the tiny voltage created by
the turntables carriage the preamp
applies the inverse of the RIAA curve
perfectly restoring the music's Naturals
balance and minimizing the size
constraints that are intrinsically
linked to the nature of the media so
we've painted a complicated and grim
picture for vinyl as a storage media the
actual truth here is that there is no
functional difference in the audio
quality between digital and analog
formats and studies showed that the
human ear and brain is not sufficiently
equipped to distinguish the difference
between sound produced from analog
signals when compared to a digital
counterpart at the very least this is
enough to debunk the notion that digital
music formats are a lesser quality
format than analog formats an important
question to ask here is why are people
that understand these concepts still
drawn to vinyl there's a number of
simple answers to this question part of
it is the nostalgia factor people have
positive personal associations with the
vinyl format from their youth and these
associations invoke an emotional state
that induces a sense of comfort and
although there are no discernible
differences in theoretical audio quality
vinyl does have a specific sound that is
imperative due to the mastering process
mastering is the process by which the
final song is mixed for the final device
it will be stored on
over the past 36 years due to the
removal of the physical limitations of
vinyl media and the spread of digitized
music songs have become increasingly
louder and increasingly more compressed
in essence this means that the sound
wave becomes compressed forcing the
quieter parts of the song to become
relatively louder and the louder parts
relatively quieter
the net effect been a louder noisier
song as a result of this trend a vast
majority of commercial music releases
have been subject to a somewhat
arbitrary loudness war that has forced
them to increase loudness to keep pace
it has also resulted in increased use of
compression of the music which some
would argue has resulted in a loss of
detail and nuance in the final sound
this development has been criticized by
a number of prominent audio engineers
and is part of the attraction towards
vinyl some people prefer vinyl for this
reason
music properly mastered for the medium
is to a certain degree immune to the
effects of the music loudness Wars and
in some cases this can mean that the
more nuanced parts of the songs are
easier to pick out for a trained ear
really though given that this same
information can be recorded on a digital
format and replayed exactly the same way
the answer to this question is that
digital and analog formats are
functionally the same in the quality of
sound produced and any preference for
one media or the other is really just
that a preference the longevity and
iconic status of the vinyl record as a
music format cannot be ignored though
despite the shortcomings we've described
it is an incredibly durable and
elegantly simple medium this is probably
best exemplified in the golden plated
record sent on Voyager 1 in September of
1977 it's hard to believe for 12 million
miles away from here this record is
floating through space its cover
contains simple instructions for
playback based on certain universal
constants and the record itself contains
a high-resolution snapshot of 200,000
years of human culture unless the
Voyager 1 suffers a direct impact or
encounter heat that may melt the record
this record in theory should out survive
even our species just as the technology
for storing music has advanced the
technology from mixing a mastering music
has to it has never been easier to get
into music production thanks to programs
like FL Studio and Ableton which give
you a virtual production room with all
the tools you need to create a sum of
your own
there's never been more information
available to learn how to use them
either with introductory classes like
this on Skillshare for FL Studio and
Ableton and many more classes to teach
you the nitty gritty of music production
like this one from grammy-nominated DJ
young guru these days you can teach
yourself pretty much any skill online
and Skillshare is a fantastic place to
do it
with professional and understandable
classes that follow a clear learning
curve you can dive in and start learning
how to do the work you love the Premium
Membership begins around ten dollars a
month for unlimited access to all
courses with the first 1,000 people to
sign up with this link will get their
first two months for free as usual
thanks for watching and thank you to all
my patreon supporters if you'd like to
see more from me
the links to my Twitter Facebook discord
server subreddit and Instagram pages are
below
[Music]
you
[Music]